Speaker 1: All right.
Yesterday, I told you that President Joe Biden
has announced he will be seeking reelection
in 2024.
This, of course, did not go unnoticed by the
failed former President Donald Trump, who
seeks to be his party's nominee in 2024 and
would, in theory, face off against Joe Biden,
assuming Joe Biden wins the Democratic primary.
Donald Trump massively, massively triggered
having a completely insane reaction, starting
a four minute statement with many of his typical
grievances and talking points about Joe Biden.
Let's look at the beginning of this reaction.
Then we'll look at some key moments and then
we will talk about Donald Trump being scared
to debate seemingly now and flipping out over
debates being scheduled without his approval.
Let's first start with the beginning of Trump's
reaction.
Better lighting.
In this video, I will admit to Joe Biden's
announcement.
Speaker 3: You could take the five worst presidents
in American history and put them together
and they would not have done the damage Joe
Biden has done to our nation in just a few
short years.
Speaker 1: To everybody who believes that.
I challenge you to present data.
Data, not conjecture.
I challenge you to present data showing the
damage Joe Biden has done.
Speaker 3: Not even close.
Thanks to Joe Biden.
Socialist spending calamity.
American families are being decimated by the
worst inflation in half a century.
Banks are failing, our currency is crashing
and the dollar will soon no longer be the
world standard, which will be our greatest
defeat in over 200 years.
Speaker 1: None of that is true.
There's just none of it is true.
Speaker 3: Real wages have been falling 24
months in a row.
In other words, under Biden, workers have
gotten a pay cut each and every month for
two straight years.
Speaker 1: Understand that real inflation
adjusted wages also fell during periods of
Trump's presidency.
It's not a completely unique thing.
Speaker 3: We have surrendered our energy
independence.
Speaker 1: We have not.
Okay, so I'm in a positive.
We have not surrendered energy independence.
We're producing more oil than than were exporting
more oil than we import.
Is it's crazy what's going on here.
Okay.
So Trump just trotting out his standard lies,
but then he got very apocalyptic and he teased
that more.
Biden will mean World War Three.
Now, remember, Trump's been predicting World
War three.
If Hillary were to have gotten elected in
2016.
He's been predicting World War three during
Biden's first term hasn't happened.
He's just always predicting World War Three.
But then he really unleashes on Joe Biden.
Speaker 3: They say Trump was right about
everything.
Well, I'm not predicting World War Three,
but I will say this.
We're very close and they're only talking
about nuclear weapons.
On top of it all.
Biden is the most corrupt president in American
history.
Speaker 1: Absolutely no evidence of that.
Speaker 3: And that's not even close.
Nobody can believe what's going on with, again,
no retribution whatsoever with such a calamitous
and failed presidency.
It is almost inconceivable that Biden would
even think of running for reelection.
You know what happened in the last election?
Speaker 1: Yeah, Biden won.
Speaker 3: They cheated and they rigged the
election.
Speaker 1: So in all honesty, my friends.
Does anyone really expect Trump to be saying
anything different?
It's been lies about the Biden administration
from day one.
It's been lies about the 2020 election from
day one.
What else does Trump have?
What can Trump retreat to?
There is nothing there.
And so this is what we're going to see.
And by the way, continuing with the transphobia
saying children are being mutilated.
Speaker 3: Our children are being indoctrinated
and mutilated by left wing freaks and zealots.
Speaker 1: I'm struggling to believe that
that is actually what is going on.
And of course, it isn't.
Expect a lot of this.
And Donald Trump is now in a tizzy, partially
because a guy named Ron DeSantis didn't rule
out running against Trump and may announce
his campaign.
And that infuriates Trump because it's not
a sign of loyalty.
And I'll be honest, to some degree, the reason
Trump is triggered about Biden running again
is Biden beat him in 2020, and Trump, no matter
what he says publicly, knows if he beat me
in 2020, he could beat me again.
And the question for Trump is, given that
he lost in 2020, how can he gain ground on
Joe Biden in 2024?
Trump's arrest and indictment may well help
him with Republican voters.
It's not helping him in the general election.
And so the mathematical problem for Trump
is you look at the map and you look at the
results of 2020, then you say, well, you know,
a lot of these states, Arizona certainly hasn't
moved to the right since 2020.
Wisconsin hasn't moved to the right since
2020.
Florida has, but Trump won Florida, so that
doesn't get him any additional electoral votes.
So Trump realizes it's a difficult map.
And whether you believe Trump believes it
was stolen or not, Trump knows if you replicate
2020 in 24, it doesn't look particularly good
for Trump.
And so Trump is scared.
And the other thing he seems scared about
is debating.
Let's talk about that next